bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi domenica quindi siamo più vicini
raga direi iniziare subito facciamo
walking match ragazzi non so che riveli
sto facendo non lo so siamo che dio non
cerchi in un transformer è questo non me
l'aveva detto
cos'è auto workplace space to start è
presa prenda a ok edita melo che ne so
io spiega rituali dove perché su 16 per
uno shock tu menti tu menti e vai cos'è
un lato un braccio oddio mi si è
infilato non lo sa che nel bene cioè
demoliamo nonni ciak
voi siete qua se siete tutti fuori
perché vi si sta small e colando la
barba all'interno non lo so c'è mi sto
mangiando dei polmoni presto e media va
bene facciamo presto il meglio allora
col col nonno presto il meglio a casa
uno shunt cioè dove ma qual è il mio
avversario non c'è quel pc di sotto
almeno dai ragazzi devo prendere padre
di york culo slam provare a beccare e
tipo pik show dove chiara dio mio ciò
posso fare tantissimo
lo spaccato la testa ed è finita anche
nel cestino fantastico bene devo fare
jean jungle deve essere epico sono
sicuro ora voglio però la formazione
etica non mi ferma nessuno
non mi ferma nesso allora aspettate da
fare
vai
oh mio dio non ci credo
l'ho presa no l'arca [ __ ] sono non
sono ancora vivo ok come non detto
your wife la faccio che cos'è che gli
user weil
io guardo che già c'era prendo potuto
fare dopo perfetto devo ammazzare mia
moglie che sono falsa perché sono morto
io è caduto anche estiva la prossima io
devo raggiungere ok ragazzi ci prova di
uccidere mia moglie non so se ci riesco
ho preso stima che in caso ci passi per
cui ho mio dio ho dato un accurata
qualcuno e quel qualcuno di sicuro non è
contento questo sono sicuri schede box
questo l'ho fatto ma questo lo faccio
sicuro abbiamo riusciva a scappare da
qui aiuto aprite cazzo aprista brave o
un pietro bastardi non c'è paura di
usarlo devo scendere in sostanza sono
quasi morto a ma devo scappare la più
belli fantastico da ramo diamoci prima
che già ovvio aiuta mio io santissimo mi
è arrivato un mattone sulla che cazzo
ragazze aiuta a iotta fingi di morto ok
a quanto pare ha funzionato fingersi
morti ragazze è una tattica che funziona
mi sono tagliato una gamba rapina ma ho
vinto
ricordatevi fingete vi assolutamente
morti nel caso cento per cento imporsi
voi ragazzi dovete scusarmi che
nell'ultimo episodio hanno fatto
l'impossible con steven anche in questo
perché non è continuo
ragazzi questo è impossibile che cazzo
succede non prezzo l'ho preso st grande
questo rock swing ed è un bed swing e un
dead swing ci posso fare devo
aggrapparmi alle gambe di mio padre ma
che cazzo sono caduta raga è impossibile
mio dio santissimo ma come cazzo
affaccia falso livello cioè non si può
addio ma che cazzo ma raga io mia
continuerò aggrapparmi a mio padre non
livello era impossibile concedetemelo
non si poteva fare ma tanto non era con
steve quindi se non giustificato o un
pene falcier part ii cos'è sta roba
devo aspettatelo no vai così grande a
chi conta che gol devo prendere allora
ragazzi non devo farlo assolutamente mai
casual che cosa assurda la palla e sulla
riga ma entrata non c'è l'arbitro deve
uscire
mio zio steve questo non è fallo jumping
the box cos'è jumping the box ragazzi
ora che devo anche fare un impossible
consiglio perché non fa un cazzo
la cielo quasi devo fare anche un
impossible diciamo così perché ancora
non ho fatti vice steve vai così di
testa la cosa mai così steve vai così
steve vai ma che ho vinto fa testa
frigia in prossimo al 99 per cento
proprio fallo raga perché di impasti
però ancora non abbiamo fatti ragazzi
non ce la faremo mai a fare un normale
imposti volte questo non è a norma le
imposte
sì sì sì sì no ma che cazzo ho vinto col
corpo ma non con la mente la vena da
ragazzi
un cazzo si ma magari se mi stacco e
cado ma ci posso credere perché spiega
di merda la parola che prima o poi ce
l'ha purtroppo 99,9 per cento prossimo
per farvi j
saluti da ciro ciro il mio pizzaiolo non
so se c'entra però ciao ce la posso fare
non ce la faccio mai steve mi era venuta
l'ispirazione di parlo di culo allora si
facci sognare stick cos'è ragazzi devono
mi è partito lo riprendono riprendo
riprendo come sono morto ragazza posso
fare
sono conciato malissimo ma cos'è sta
roba ragazzi e nuovo tipo di ruota la
ruota steve devo riuscire a fermo stival
ora ce la puoi fare senza no no che
cazzo fai steve ti servo allora questa è
una cosa un po strana steam reattore o
cazzo
questa è un nuovo gioco per bambini devo
riuscire a si si si
non ci credo
il tutto zio no ragazzi questa è stata
la vittoria fantastica e anche oggi
l'impossible è stato no mi chiedete come
l'ho fatto perché non lo so ma l'ho
fatto anche oggi
ok è fa vj sei un dio grazie mille fa vj
ce la fai
la mappe da gente mistica quello che mi
piace mi piace tantissimo a casa c'era
york aspettatemi ha distratto c'è io che
cosa fa uk c'è stata no io cosa fai
togliti la casa ok perfetto dove devo
andare non lo so mi sono aggrappato al
no aspettate devo riuscire a scendere
grande lo zio edy non ci credo non ci
credo
wired through per poi j2 geo fairy tail
grande vaibhavi sul cd steve e vinci ci
sono tutti noi ragazzi queste fanta ci
sono tutti c'è anche un nuovo
personaggio la madre di york che non ho
mai assi nel primo nel primo episodio di
apb se l'avevo chiamata va bene ce la
posso fare
allora padre mio che è andato ma come
ucciso news no fantastico devo uccidere
steve no ma rinuncia libro mai a steve
si ma ferite il tu sei un genio fare i
livelli ti ho già giocato due livelli se
un fenomeno c'è una guerra che roba è
fantastico
vabbè ho fatto fuori ed il fake nonno
ciak è andato ma non ha però mai a
prendere steve questa spada a meno che
non faccia un tiro della madonna non ce
la farò mai però ho preso non lo cercano
in un modo assurdo questa è buona
no che questo l'ho preso non sa che il
key manca steve già 200 spadaccia potrò
fare una volta no perfetto non è
possibile non mi devo uccidere da solo
almeno quello ragazzi ci rinuncio maller
closer fabi genio che ci provo cosa la
devo è una cosa ai tavoli cede volevo
staccarmi quando grande no fun bello
questo continua la testa
spike colpa vj questo lo devo fare
questo devo fare assolutamente dov'è
eccolo questo
le soddisfazioni ragazzi le
soddisfazioni
poi faccio pagare nei livelli tipo sword
tro però in questi vinco senza neanche
mettere mano alla tastiera
vabbè ryan e faccio io veramente vi
giuro passerei la giornata a giocare in
via livelli perché sono fantasie ne sono
troppi cos'è fa vj potato cioè vabbè
favi già in moto ranfa vige il motore
non faccio l'ultima va bene faccio
questa perché miss fiera devo farla col
padre di look per forza ma i ragazzi ce
la posso fare io voto run fantastico
vinto mi dicono ciò posso fare la canon
è impossibile non è impossibile qualcuno
avrà vinto e vincerò con nonno ciak con
nonno jacques mai nonna ok non aspettate
che devo girare i razzi così tipo no no
no no no no no no sì no no sì no no
si no ma che cazzo di idiota sono non ci
posso credere o no ma come fai a non si
può essere più efficienti regalo fatto
vado va bene così perché la prossima
volta cercherà di fare di più per chi ha
veramente aumentano a dismisura i miei
livelli ragazzi per questo episodio la
chiudo qui e vi dove è piaciuto lasciate
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione a sedersi tra iscritti
iscrivetevi ci rivediamo in un prossimo
nido bene ragazzi